The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hi.
In the last unit, we
introduced the notion
of the structure of vectors in
terms of arrows in the plane.
And today, we want to talk about
the added geometric property
of what I could call
three-dimensional vectors
or three-dimensional arrows.
Now before I say that-- I
guess I've already said it--
but before I say
any more about it,
let me point out,
of course, that this
is a matter of semantics.
Obviously an arrow, being a
line, has only one dimension,
be it in the direction of the
x-axis, be it in the x-y plane,
or be it in
three-dimensional space.
When we say
"three-dimensional vectors,"
we do not negate the fact that
we're talking about arrows,
but rather that we are dealing
with a coordinate system which
takes into consideration the
fact that the line is drawn
through three-dimensional space.
In other words, where
as I call the lecture
three-dimensional vectors
or arrows-- and by the way,
both in the notes
and as I'm lecturing,
I will very often, whenever
I write the word "vector,"
put "arrow" in
parentheses, whenever
I write the word "arrow,"
put "vector" in parentheses
so that you can see
the juxtaposition
between these two, the
geometry versus the physical or
mathematical concept.
But the idea is
something like this.
In three-dimensional space,
we have a natural extension
of Cartesian coordinates.
Rather than talk
about the x-y plane,
we pick a third axis, a
third number line, which
goes through the origin,
perpendicular to the x-y plane,
and which has the sense
that if the x-axis is
rotated into the y-axis through
the positive 90-degree angle
here, that the z-axis
is in the direction
in which a right-handed
screw would turn.
I won't belabor this.
It's done very, very
nicely in the textbook.
And I'm sure that you have seen
this type of coordinate system
before.
If you haven't,
it's something that
takes a matter of some 20
or 30 seconds to pick up.
But at any rate,
what we're saying
is, let's imagine this
three-dimensional coordinate
system, three-dimensional
Cartesian coordinates.
The convention is that
just as, in the plane,
we label the point by its x and
y components, in three space,
a point is labeled by its
x, y, and z components.
So for example, if I take a
vector in three-space-- meaning
what?
It's a line that goes through
three-dimensional space-- I
again shift it
parallel to itself,
so it begins at my origin.
And at the risk of causing
some confusion here,
I still think it's worth doing.
Let me call the
vector A, and let
me call the point at which the
vector terminates the point A.
And let's suppose that the point
A has coordinates A_1, A_2,
A_3.
The reason that this
doesn't make much difference
if you get confused is
that if the vector, which
originates at the
origin, terminates
at the point whose
coordinates a_1, a_2,
and a_3, then the components
of that vector will have what?
The i component will be a_1.
The j component will be a_2.
And by the way, we let
k be the unit vector
in the positive z direction.
And the k component will be a_3.
To see this thing
pictorially, notice
the three-dimensional
effect of the vector A.
It means that if we drop a
perpendicular from the head
of A to the x-y plane, then,
you see, this distance is a_1.
This distance is a_2.
And this height is a_3.
And notice, again, in terms of
adding vectors head to tail et
cetera, notice that as a vector,
this would be the vector a_1*i.
This would be the vector a_2*j.
And this would be
the vector a_3*k.
In other words, the vector A
is the sum of the three vectors
a_1*i, a_2*j, and a_3*k.
In other words,
to summarize this,
the vector A is simply what?
a_1*i, plus a_2*j, plus a_3*k.
And again, notice the
juxtapositioning, if you wish,
between the components
of the vector
and the coordinates
of the point.
Also, we can get ahold of
the magnitude of this vector.
Remember, the magnitude
is the length.
And how can we figure out
the length of this vector?
Notice that, by the
way, the geometry
gets much tougher in
three-dimensional space.
But I want to show you something
interesting in a minute.
Let's suffer through the
geometry for a minute.
Let's see how we can find
the length of the vector A.
Well, notice, by the way,
that A happens to be--
or the magnitude of A
happens to be the hypotenuse
of a right triangle.
What right triangle is it?
It's the right
triangle that joins
the origin-- let me call
this point here B-- and A.
In other words, triangle
OBA is a right triangle
because OB is in the
x-y plane and AB is
perpendicular to the x-y plane.
Therefore, by the Pythagorean
theorem, the magnitude of A
will be the square root of the
square of the magnitude of OB
plus the square of
the magnitude of AB.
On the other hand, notice that
OCB is also a right triangle.
So by the Pythagorean
theorem, the length of OB
is the square root of a_1
squared plus a_2 squared.
And therefore, you see, by
the Pythagorean theorem,
the square of the
magnitude of A is
this squared plus this squared.
In other words,
the magnitude of A
is the square root of a_1
squared plus a_2 squared
plus a_3 squared.
In other words, in
Cartesian coordinates,
to find the magnitude
of a vector,
you need only take the
positive square root
of the sum of the squares
of the components.
It's a regular distance formula,
the Pythagorean theorem.
By the way, just a
very, very quick review
from part one of our
course-- remember
that technically
speaking, the square root
is a double-valued function.
Namely, any positive number
has two square roots.
All right?
In other words, the
square root of 16 is 4.
It's also negative 4.
But by convention, when
we don't indicate a sign,
we're always referring to
the positive square root.
And that's fine.
Because after all,
the magnitude--
the length of an
arrow-- is always
looked upon as being what?
Some non-negative number.
Notice that the negativeness
is taken care of by the sense.
OK?
And this is what's
rather interesting.
I think it's worth noting.
If we use Cartesian
coordinates in one dimension,
all you have is the
x-axis, in which case
any vector is some scale or
multiple of the unit vector i.
In other words, A
is equal to a_1*i.
In this case, the magnitude
of A is just what?
It's the square
root of a_1 squared.
And notice that means the
positive square root--
notice, by the way, that
that's the usual meaning
of absolute value.
After all, if a_1
were already positive,
taking the positive square
root of its square root--
of its square.
These tongue twisters.
The positive square
root of the square
would give you the
number back again.
On the other hand,
if a_1 were negative,
and then you square it, and then
take the positive square root,
all you do is change
the sign of a_1.
And since it was negative,
changing its sign
makes it positive.
So this is the usual
absolute value, all right?
Now in terms of
the previous unit,
we saw that in
two-dimensional space,
using i and j as
our basic vectors,
that if A was the
vector a_1*i plus a_2*j,
then the magnitude of A, again,
by the Pythagorean theorem,
was just a square root of
a_1 squared plus a_2 squared.
And now we've seen
that structurally--
even though geometrically
it was harder to show--
that if A in three-dimensional
space is a_1*i plus a_2*j plus
a_3*k, then A is what?
The positive square
root of a_1 squared
plus a_2 squared
plus a_3 squared.
And notice you see this
structural resemblance.
This is a beautiful
Why is it a beautiful
structural resemblance?
Because now, maybe we're
getting the feeling
that once our rules and
recipes are made up,
we don't have to worry about
how difficult the geometry is.
In other words,
except for the fact
that you have an extra
component to worry about here,
there is no basic
difference structurally
between finding the length of a
vector in one-dimensional space
or in three-dimensional space.
And in fact, another reason that
I'm harping on this is the fact
that in a little while-- meaning
within the next few lessons--
we are going to be talking
about some horrible thing called
n-dimensional space, which
geometrically cannot be drawn,
but which analytically preserves
the same structure that
we're talking about here.
You see, the whole bag is
still this idea of structure.
We're trying to emphasize
that the recipes remain
the same independently
of the dimension.
And just to carry this idea a
few steps further, what we're
saying is, remember in the last
unit, we talked about the fact
that the nice thing
about i and j components
was that the definition
for adding two vectors
was that if they were in
terms of i and j components,
you just add it
component by component?
Well again, without
belaboring the point
and leaving the details to
the text and to the exercises,
let's keep in mind that
it's relatively easy to show
that the same formal definition
of addition-- namely,
placing the arrows head
to tail, et cetera--
forgetting about Cartesian
coordinates, but notice
the definition of
addition doesn't
mention the coordinate system.
It just says put the vectors
head to tail, et cetera.
And what I'm saying
is it's easy to show,
under those conditions, that
if A is the vector a_1*i plus
a_2*j plus a_3*k, and B is the
vector b_1*i plus b_2*j plus
b_3*k, then you still
add vectors the same way
in three-space as
you did in two-space.
Again, the geometric arguments
are a little bit more
sophisticated, if only
because it's harder
to draw three
dimensions to scale
than it is two dimensions.
But the idea is what?
A plus B is just
obtained by adding what?
The two i components,
the two j components,
the two k components.
And similarly, for
scalar multiplication,
in the same way in terms
of i and j components,
you simply multiplied each
complement by the scalar c.
If c is any number and A is
still the vector a_1*i plus
a_2*j plus a_3k, the scalar
multiple c times A turns out
to be c*a_1*i plus
c*a_3*j plus c*a_3*k.
That you just multiply
component by component.
And by the way, don't lose
track of this important point,
that the scalar multiple c*A
means the same thing in two
dimensions as it did three.
Because after all, when you draw
that vector, once that arrow
is drawn, it's a one-dimensional
thing if you pick as your axis
the line of action of
the particular arrow.
In other words,
scalar multiplication
means the same thing.
What's happening is that
you're looking at it in terms
of different components.
You're looking at it in terms of
i, j, and k, rather than just i
and j, or in terms of any
other coordinate system.
But carrying this
out in particular,
notice then, the connection
between the vector minus B--
negative B-- and the
vector negative 1 times
B. Namely, the vector negative
B, which has the same magnitude
and direction as B,
but the opposite sense,
is the same way as saying what?
Multiply B by minus 1.
Because that gives you a vector
which has the same magnitude--
namely 1 times as much as
B-- the same direction,
and the opposite sense.
In other words, the
vector negative B,
in three-dimensional space,
is minus b_1 i, minus b_2 j,
minus b_3 k.
And therefore, since A minus B
still means A plus negative B,
the vector A minus B
is simply obtained how?
You subtract the
same way as we did
in ordinary one-dimensional
analytic geometry,
in terms of a number line.
In other words, you
subtract component
by component-- subtracting what?
The first vector minus the
corresponding component
of the second vector.
In other words, in Cartesian
coordinates, the vector A
minus B-- once we know a_1, a_2,
and a_3 as the components of A,
b_1, b_2, and b_3 as
the components of B,
we just subtract
component by component
to get this particular
result. And this is, I
think, very important
to understand.
By the same token,
as simple as this is,
it's going to
cause-- if we're not
careful-- great
misinterpretation.
Namely, the vector arithmetic
that we're talking about
does not depend on
Cartesian coordinates.
Vectors or arrows, as
we're looking at them,
and the arrows exist no
matter what coordinate system
we're using.
What is particularly
important, however,
is that many of the luxuries
of using vector arithmetic
hinge on using
Cartesian coordinates.
Now what do I mean by that?
Well, let me just
emphasize: Note the need
for Cartesian coordinates.
Let me talk instead,
you see, about something
called polar coordinates.
Now later on,
we're going to talk
about polar coordinates
in more detail-- in fact,
in very, very much more detail.
But for the time
being, let's view polar
coordinates simply as
a radar-type thing,
as a range-and-bearing
type navigation.
Namely, in polar
coordinates, the way
you specify a vector
in the plane, say,
is you specify its length, which
we'll call r, and the angle
that it makes with the positive
x-axis, that we'll call theta.
In other words, in polar
coordinates, the vector A,
which I've labeled
r_2 comma theta_2 ,
that would indicate that
the magnitude of A is r_2.
And that the angle that A
makes with the positive x-axis
is theta_2.
And when I label the vector
B as r_1 comma theta_1,
it's simply my way of
saying that the magnitude
of the vector B is some
length, which we'll call r_1.
And the angle that B makes
with the positive x-axis
is some angle which
we'll call theta_1.
OK?
Perfectly well-defined
system, isn't it?
In other words, if I tell
you the range and bearing,
I've certainly given
you as much information
as if I told you the
i and j components.
Now here's the important point,
the real kicker to this thing.
And that is that the vector
A minus B-- and A minus B
is what?
It's this vector here.
And by the way, notice how
vector arithmetic goes.
How could you tell
quickly whether this
is A minus B or B minus A?
We talked about this
in the previous unit,
and had exercises
and discussion on it.
But notice again, the
structure of vector arithmetic.
If you look at addition,
what is this vector here?
This is the vector which
must be added on to B
to give the vector A. And that,
by definition, is called what?
A minus B. A minus
B is what vector?
The vector you must add on
to B to yield A. Subtraction
is still the
inverse of addition.
And hopefully by now, you should
be becoming much less fearful
of this vector notation,
that structurally, it's
the same as our first
unit of arithmetic.
Well, numerical arithmetic,
OK, the more regular type,
ordinary type of arithmetic.
But here's the important point.
This vector is still
A minus B. But I
claim that it's trivial to
see that this vector is not
the vector whose
magnitude is r_2 minus r_1
and whose angle of bearing
is theta_2 minus theta_1.
Now the word "trivial" is a very
misleading word in mathematics.
One of our famous
mathematical anecdotes
is the professor who said
that a proof was trivial.
The student says, "It
doesn't seem trivial to me."
Their professor says,
"Well, it is trivial."
He didn't quite
see it in a hurry.
He says, "Wait here."
He ran down to his office.
Came up three hours later
with a ream of papers
that he had written on,
bathed in perspiration,
and a big smile.
And he said, "I was right.
It was trivial."
So just because what
I think is trivial
may not be what you
think is trivial,
let me go through this statement
in more computational detail.
What I'm saying is, let v
denote the vector that we
called A minus B before.
Notice that in terms of what
the vectors A and B are,
this length is r_1.
This length is r_2.
And notice that since this
whole angle was theta_2,
and the angle from here to here
was theta_1, this angle in here
must be the difference between
those two angles, which
is theta_2 minus theta_1.
Now notice that this
is still a triangle.
The length of this
triangle is still
expressible in terms of these
sides and the included angle.
But you may recall from plane
trigonometry and our refresher
of that in the first
part of our course-- part
one-- that to find the
third side of a triangle,
given two sides and
the included angle,
one must use the Law of Cosines.
In other words, the magnitude
of v has what property?
That its square is equal to the
sum of the squares of these two
sides minus twice the
product of these two
lengths times the cosine
of the included angle.
In other words, this is just--
I hope this shows up all right--
this is the Law of Cosines.
And if it's difficult to
read, don't bother reading it.
It's still the Law of
Cosines, and hopefully you
recognize it as such.
In other words, to find
the magnitude of v,
it's not just r_1
or r_2 minus r_1.
It's the square root of r_1
squared plus r_2 squared minus
2r_1*r_2 cosine
theta_2 minus theta_1.
Can you use polar
coordinates if you want?
The answer is you bet you can.
But when you do use it, make
sure that whenever you're
going to find the magnitude,
that you don't just
subtract the two magnitudes.
You have to use this.
And by the way, notice I haven't
even gone into this part,
because it's irrelevant
from the point of view
that I'm trying
to emphasize now.
This mess just gives you
the magnitude of a vector.
It doesn't even tell you
what direction it's in.
I have to still do a
heck of a lot of geometry
if I want to find out
what this angle here
is-- a lot of work involved.
I can use polar
coordinates, but I
lose some of the luxury
of Cartesian coordinates.
In fact, notice that the
vector whose magnitude
is r_2 minus r_1 and
whose angle of bearing
is theta_2 minus theta_1,
can also be computed.
Namely, how do we find
theta_2 minus theta_1?
Well up here, we have
the angle theta_2.
We have the angle theta_1.
We computed theta_2
minus theta_1.
I can now mark off that angle
here, theta_2 minus theta_1.
I can now take a
circle of radius r_1--
well, why even say a
circle-- mark off the length
r_1 onto r_2, assuming r_2 is
the greater of the two lengths.
That difference will
be r_2 minus r_1.
In other words, if I
swing an arc over here,
this would r_1 also.
This distance here
would be r_2 minus r_1.
I take that distance, and
mark it off down here.
And what vector is this?
This is the vector, which
in polar coordinates
would have its magnitude
equal to r_2 minus r_1,
and have its angle equal
to theta_2 minus theta_1.
And all I want you
to see is no matter
how you slice it, just
from this picture alone,
this vector is not the
same as this vector.
And by the way, don't make
the mistake of saying,
gee, the way you've
draw them, they
look like they could
be the same length.
Remember that even if by
coincidence these two vectors
had the same length,
you must remember
that vector equality requires
not just the same magnitude,
but the same direction.
And even with the same
direction, the same sense.
What should be
obvious is, at least
based on this one picture, that
the direction of this vector
certainly is not the same as
the direction of this vector.
In other words, I guess I've
said this many times in part
one, and even though it comes
out like phony facetiousness,
I mean it quite sincerely.
Given two vectors in
polar coordinates,
one certainly has
the right to invent
the vector r_2 minus r_1
comma theta_2 minus theta_1.
You certainly have
the right to do that,
but you don't have the right
to call that A minus B. What
I meant by being facetious
is, you have the right
to call it that, but
you're going to be wrong.
Because A minus B has
already been defined.
And all we have now
is a choice of what
the answer looks like in a
particular coordinate system.
And by the way, just
as a quick review,
assuming that you've studied
different number bases at one
time in your careers, this
has come up many times
in the mathematics
curriculum under the heading
of "Number-versus-Numeral,"
or more generally,
I call it the heading of
"Name-versus-Concept."
For example, consider
the number 6.
6 is this many, and no matter
how you slice it again,
this many is an even number.
It breaks up into bundles
of 2 with none left over.
OK?
If you were to write 6 as a
base 5 numeral, it's what?
One bundle of 5
with 1 left over.
In other words, notice
that the number 6
ends in an odd digit in base 5.
In other words, the
test for evenness
by looking at the last digit
depends on the number base.
In other words, in an
even base, a number
is even if its
units digit is even.
In an odd base, a
number may or may not
be even, depending on whether
its units digit is even.
In other words, the
actual test that you're
using-- the actual convenient
computational property--
depends on the base.
But the important point
is that 6 is always even,
independently of a number base.
In fact, the number
6 as six tally marks
was invented long before
place-value enumeration.
You see what I'm driving at?
In other words, the number
concept stays the same.
The concept stays the same.
What the thing
looks like in terms
of a particular set
of names, that's
what depends on the
names that you choose.
All right?
I think that is very,
very important to see.
The vector properties
do not change.
The convenient
computational recipes
do depend on what coordinate
system you're choosing.
And that's one of the
reasons-- the same as
in part one of this course--
why we find it very convenient,
whenever possible, to use
Cartesian coordinates.
OK?
And let me just
summarize this some more.
Structurally, this is
very important here.
Structurally, arrow arithmetic
is the same for both two
and three dimensions.
For example, without
belaboring the point,
whether we're dealing with
two-dimensional arrows
or three-dimensional arrows,
A plus B is B plus A.
A plus (B plus C) is equal
to (A plus B) plus C.
and let me just say, et cetera,
and not belabor this particular
point, that structurally, we
cannot tell the difference
between two-dimensional vectors
and three-dimensional vectors.
What we can tell the
difference between, I guess,
is the geometry.
The geometry may be more
difficult to visualize
in three-space
than in two-space.
But structurally, we
cannot tell the difference.
And I guess this is what
this thing is all about,
that as you read the textbook
and do your assignment,
there is going to be a
tendency on your part
to try to rely on diagrams.
And boy, you have to be an
expert in descriptive geometry
to be able to take a view of
something in three dimensions,
and try to get its true lengths,
as you look along various axes
and lines of sight.
The beauty is going to
be that as we continue on
with this course, we will
use geometry for motivation.
But once we have motivated
things by geometry,
we will extract those rules that
we can use even in cases where
we can't see the picture.
In much the same way, going
back to our first lecture
when we talked about
why b to the 0 equals 1,
we made up our
rules to make sure
that they would conform to the
nice computational recipes that
were prevalent in the
more simple cases.
And we are going to play
this thing to the hilt.
We're going to really
exploit this and explore it
in future lectures, and in
fact, throughout the rest
of this course.
But more about that next time.
And until next time, good bye.
Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.